a coincidence or an attempt to sabotage
the nuclear talks
an attack on an iranian ship in the red
sea iran says the mv service was being
used as a base to support logistical
and anti-piracy operations but it's long
been believed the cargo ship was used by
iran's revolutionary guards
and israel quickly emerged as a possible
suspect for the attack
last month israel had accused iran of
targeting one of its vessels
but neither country is admitting
responsibility for either incident
in the case of the mv service it's
believed a mine was attached to the ship
as the nuclear talks in vienna got
underway it's hard to
consider this a coincidence maybe it is
but you know the good news is that the
entire world
supports a return to the nuclear deal by
the us and iran
with a couple of notable exceptions um
and i think the israelis
the saudis and the emiratis and then
congressional republicans
are the the parties who are the vast
minority but who do not want to deal and
are going to do everything possible to
try to
upset this process iran wants all
sanctions imposed by the united states
lifted before it returns to its
compliance of the nuclear deal
when former u.s president donald trump
pulled the u.s out of the agreement in
2018
iran began increasing its uranium
enrichment beyond accepted levels
despite the challenges still faced in
securing a new cooperation
iranian president hassan rouhani is
upbeat about the vienna talks
we have no doubt that this success was
achieved thanks to the resilience of the
iranian nation
and their national integration the u.s
administration is admitting that
they have no other way but to negotiate
and suggest direct talks
if iran wants or indirect talks through
the p4 plus one countries
but there's still a long way to go we do
see this as a constructive
and certainly welcome step and in the
end
we hope that we are able to
leave vienna return to united states our
negotiating team i should say with a
better understanding
of a roadmap for how we get to that in
state
mutual compliance so far both the united
states and iran are positive about the
talks
even though they're not talking to each
other directly the european negotiators
hope that some form of agreement can be
reached
but some regional countries are not
happy with joe biden's policy of
engaging with iran
and is concerned here in tehran that
there may be attempts to derail the
negotiations
assad beg al-jazeera tehran